okay so now here we are a few years ago
I'm doing dice you understand yeah I
took a coffee break and I'm redoing the
carpets in my house I do the whole house
yeah
with broke the boys room no way piss
Berber they were one when I did the
Berber okay they're in their 20s what
kind of crime is gone what kind of
carpet now the different house what kind
of carpet is it now
mind your business work on it like
different rooms had different themes all
right okay Jesus all right so I have the
guy do my whole house a carpet and he
winds up talking me into this black
carpet in my room cuz you know at any
given moment you would have checked you
want to throw on the floor that's part
of the reason for carpet I don't want to
bang around a wooden floor you have a
bad let me let me explain something
anybody could do it in the bed I got it
a bed now in them would have yeah but
that we could do it in the forest and
then on a roller coaster but the bed is
for [ __ ] no the roller coasters is
not gonna happen okay the forest
I don't hike yeah okay so like for
instance I got this I got this giant red
shag area rug 12 by 15 or 14 in my
bathroom it's beyond belief wool great I
don't buy the cheap [ __ ] we didn't ask
I don't even synthetic you want you want
walk-in ok there's your chick getting
ready for the big Saturday night date
that she pressured you into to take it
to a restaurant that you don't want to
go to and sit there FD eat stuffed
because we didn't spend enough time in
the restaurant and she wants another
[ __ ] drink anyway because god forbid
they walk out and they're not falling
all over the [ __ ] place yeah
looking like a lady walk out walking
into [ __ ] walls talking loud yeah I
forbid that night doesn't happen so I
come in the bathroom while she's getting
ready she's in the [ __ ] the panties
with the Hef [ __ ] bra
whatever ooh la la and I'm looking so
you grab a bite your hair you throw her
on the [ __ ] rug you give a two three
pumps and you throw it back at the
makeup and you go that's how beautiful I
think you were and you only did one I
compliment only got here for makeup on
and you're banging around the red rug
already aah she's gotta be thinking I
can't even begin to imagine what happens
with bowties done yeah yeah but now I
gotta wait for the restaurant and the
[ __ ] she wants to talk about when we
have no idea what I went to a bun cake I
never what she says okay when she brings
that stuff up do you feign interest or
do you go to shut up
no I don't say shut up because I want to
continue to bang you I so you don't go
along with her right and you hear [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah you know and uh no the
new girlfriend's very smart the new girl
he seems very bright she's like somebody
she's got I don't want to say where she
worked but she's a career girl you know
what I mean I don't give a lot of
information out about I don't want to
know anything about her no I just don't
want the people listening to know what's
gonna know anything about her well they
will if I say I know but I know but you
don't I'm not good I said I'm not gonna
what can I just see it because we have
to because we I want to get back to the
one leg up
oh I have something to do one leg up I
want to know how I have something to say